stoppt die maskenpflicht für unsere
alten ich weiß ich sollte endlich mit
dem Thema Masken aufhören mir raten auch
schon Freunde ich sei vielleicht etwas
verfolgt von den Masken und ich glaube
sie haben auch recht ich verstehe dass
ich da Menschen Sorgen um mich machen
aber ich habe sehr wenig Verständnis
dafür dass nicht alle Bürger beim
Anblick der maskenlosen Politiker auf
dem Oktoberfest auf die Barrikaden gehen
während es Kinder gibt die in den
Schulen mit Maske sitzen müssen also
Shira wahnsinn was in diesem Land
vorgeht aber was für mich besonders
grotesk ist die Menschen in Altenheimen
werden zur Maske wieder gezwungen und
das wie ich ja dann finde in den eigenen
vier Wänden schließlich leben sie ja
dort diese Regelung gilt ab dem 1
Oktober 2022 das ist halt das was man
gemeinsam vereint dem
Lauterbach nein ich muss kurz nochmal da
hat man den Lauterbach also als Geschenk
die alten gegeben so wie ich vielleicht
das Buch von Herrn Bosbach jetzt wollen
dass Sie heute hier